avec nous pour en parler stéphane dubois
dirigeant du cabinet du bois est associé
et cofondateur d econoclaste monsieur
dubois bienvenus bonjour merci alors la
caisse d'epargne annonce donc elle va
expérimenter le statut d'indépendant
dans certaines de ses agences c'est
selon elle pour être mieux représentées
au niveau du milieu rural parfois de
déserter est-ce que selon vous c'est un
bon argument
non c'est un non sens sur le sujet parce
que aujourd'hui on met en opposition aux
fins de comptes indépendants et salariés
et c'est pas ça le met le vrai sujet
première chose il faut rectifier le tir
de trois articles j'ai vu dans le monde
ce matin justement de cette association
aujourd'hui d'un produit de la cgc tu
appelles les syndicats on sait on
s'aperçoit qu'on tire sur le sujet du
l'indépendant conques le salarié le
conseil sera moins meilleur soit moins
de bonne qualité parce que le salarié il
est pas incentive et et le commercial
indépendant va toucher une commission
donc le conseil va être mauvais ça faut
arrêter moi j'ai fait vingt ans
d'indépendance dans mon cabinet et quand
vous avez des clients devant vous ce qui
est important c'est leur donner le
meilleur des conseils la réglementation
hélas cette personne c'est je ne tire
pas dessus mais ça m'a fait un peu
sursauter la réglementation vous oblige
en tant qu'indépendant de publier vos
frais vos honoraires
c'est à dire que dès l'entrée en
relation je me dois de vous dire combien
je gagne sur quel type de produit et
comment je suis rémunéré ce qui n'est
pas toujours très clair dans le milieu
bancaire
donc on peut pas dire que c'est un
tsunami aujourd'hui ça existe déjà dans
le monde du courtage en assurances vous
allez dans un courtier à faire la
personne il est indépendant
vous allez chez un courtier alliance il
est indépendant vous allez chez un
courtier aimé ma ils sont indépendants
donc qu'est-ce qu'il a donnée vents vont
chez des courtiers et savent qu'ils ont
affaire à des indépendants ne se sera
pas véritablement la même chose pour les
siens un conseiller bancaire
ouais c'est quand même le one faillites
bancaires alors moi je pense que ça fera
pschitt
pour une raison assez simple vous avez
dit tout à l'heure le côté un autre
entrepreneur faut savoir que d'un point
de vue réglementaire ce statut d'autres
entreprises est interdit c'est assez
bien réglementé sur le sujet là et mer
qui va gérer tous quels conseils
d'investissements financiers pour la
vente de comptes titres et de ces pays
et là on va appeler la cpr qui lui va
être là en autorité tutelle pour vendre
tout ce qui va être produit d'assurance
et de courtage d'assurance vie non vit
donc ses deux métiers différents
déjà faudra déjà voir si les salariés
ont la capacité la compétence juridique
suffisante pour obtenir leur statut et
leurs diplômes parce qu'il faut quand
même savoir que si vous êtes aujourd'hui
conseillère clientèle bancaire vous ne
pouvez pas automatiquement switcher sans
une formation voire même à master 2 pour
avoir le droit d'exercer une activité il
va falloir une formation complémentaire
donc si vous voulez je pense qu'elle a
déjà beaucoup alors ça c'est critique
personnelle mais vu le niveau de
certains conseillers clientèle je ne
crois pas vraiment la capacité d obtenir
une licence en gestion de patrimoine
parce que là va falloir retourner 24
mois à l'école et demain matin ils sont
pas près de se lever donc le but c'est
pas ça c'est vraiment c'est pas un coup
de gueule mais c'est un non-sens la bnp
paribas via cortal consors à l'époque
l'avait fait nous l'a proposé
on l'a fait pendant deux ans ça n'a pas
tenu pourquoi parce que ça ne tient pas
parce que l'indépendant est indépendant
il veut pouvoir proposer les produits
qu'ils décident donc aujourd'hui vous
aurez quoi dans l'établissement bancaire
des indépendants sur le statut qu'ils
vont pouvoir proposer des produits de la
banque
en gros on changera pas le seul il y
aura rien de nouveau sous le soleil et
je vous dirais même très rapidement
l'établissement bancaire en fin de
compte ce n'est pas le problème de
l'indépendance du nombre d'indépendants
c'est le problème que la banque n'a plus
de marge c'est qu'aujourd'hui la banque
pour s'occuper d'une clientèle retail
sur lequel il ne gagne plus d'argent ils
ne peuvent plus continuer à payer les
salaires le vrai problème est là par
ailleurs alors justement si on part du
principe que les banques souffrent et
qu'elles sont en manque de financement
s'attend en tout cas l'argument de la
caisse d'epargne qui va instaurer le
statut d'indépendant parce qu'elles
n'arrivent plus à payer ses employés
dans les milieux ruraux y est une pâte
d'autre solution que d'avoir recours aux
indépendants il y aurait peut-être fallu
vérifier une chose c'est que vous savez
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui les taux bas les
taux bas c'est un poison long très long
qui enquêtent en train pardon de tous
tout empoisonné les crédits immobiliers
il ya plus de marge
les banques commencent à dire les
courtiers en crédit j'en veux plus parce
que j'ai tout un staff qui s'occupe qui
vont s'occuper d'une partie de courtage
je préfère à la limite perdre mais
courtiers en crédits est peut-être
récupérer quelques clients directs j'ai
pur c'est une bêtise
ils vont se faire très très mal à jouer
à ce jeu là pareil de l'autre côté les
assurances vie ne rapportent plus rien
sur le fond monétaire en euro même
certaines compagnies dation son arrêté
de distribuer le fonds en euros dans
certains de leurs contrats donc il ya
les autres que l'autorité de commissions
et de contrôle financière qui est
désolant qu arrêter de financer au delà
30%
vous allez vous brûler les ailes là
cette année un million de logements
vendus
deux à trois cents mille personnes qui
sont hors des clous de l'endettement
donc elles font aujourd'hui il ya les
taux battu le marché le problème qu'on
va avoir c'est que il n'y a pas de
solution ou remonte les taux et les
banques font de la marge
ou alors les particuliers seront prêts à
payer un service mais le service espère
un jour ou l'autre
qu'elle soit sur un indépendant ou sur
une banque est ce qu'on est prêt à payer
comme alors je vais me faire huer mais
les modèles anglo-saxons des fiz à dire
que dans certaines banques aux états
unis ou en angleterre
vous faites quoi que ce soit on vous
prend des honoraires on vous prend des
fiz
on vous prend une marge voilà c'est
l'avenir peut-être je sais pas mais
honnêtement ce combat de l'un à l'autre
c'est juste une fait un fait pardon que
la caisse d'epargne c'est pas bête sur
le papier mais ça va déclencher ainsi ce
parce que tout de suite les
syndicalistes vont prendre ça en disant
oui l'indépendance dans le débat va
encore être faussés et ça c'est bien
dommage c'est plutôt de dire on n'a plus
la marge on a plus de traces et s'est
dit vous pouvez comprendre que certains
à des fins certains syndicalistes
peuvent opposer le statut d'indépendant
à travailler c'est lui a du coup le même
tout à fait et moi je vais dans leur
sens
on est en train de tuer d'entreprises en
france et le salarié avec merci monsieur
dubois je rappelle que vous êtes co
fondateur d econoclaste marc savard
était chez vous